there is an eerie silence in the three
powers Plaza that is the center of
government in Brazil it's close to
everyone but police investigators an
abandoned and battered police truck is
now part of a major investigation here
forensics teams are working their way
through the interior of the Supreme
Court overrun by anti-government
protesters on Sunday
across the square they're trying to fix
up the presidential Palace
the mob smashed their way in here as
well destroying artwork and trashing
officers
he says the protesters came ready to
Stage their takeover of the buildings he
says the police simply failed to respond
everyone
foreign
who carried out the attack who organized
it and what the police did or didn't do
will all be looked at in the
investigation
what's become apparent is that bolsonaro
supporters had been messaging each other
for weeks before the interaction took
place organizing such an event to happen
which leads investigators to think that
it really was a very well organized
event and some within the administration
are saying that it could happen again
hundreds of people arrested at the scene
and now being housed in the gymnasium of
the country's police training academy in
Brasilia they're posting their own
videos
as each case is heard the accused are
then taken away to proper prisons where
they will await trial
families wait outside for any news most
say they support their family members
we are here fighting for our Liberty
he
heard it through
we only
we are we only award that room really
there are too many facts
we are the side of the facts the true
parallels between what happened here and
the storming of the Capitol building in
Washington DC two years ago a clear
just like the United States Brazil is
now contemplating the reality the
Democracy can be very fragile
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Brasilia